vamos a decir que ese subíndice ca desde
caa1 hasta 100 denota la serie infinita
de la sucesión geométrica cuyo primer
término es caminos uno entre k factorial
y la razón común es de 1 sobre k
entonces el valor de 100 al cuadrado
entre 100 factorial más la suma desde
acá igual a 1 hasta 100 de esta
expresión que tengo aquí del valor
absoluto de cuadrada menos 3 camas 1
todo esto multiplicado por ese subíndice
que es y bueno lo primero que vamos a
hacer para responder esta pregunta tan
grande que tenemos aquí es encontrar a
quien se refiere ese subíndice k ese
subíndice k tiene como primer término
acá menos 1 entrega factorial y después
a este primer término lo vamos a
multiplicar por la razón
primero la razón elevado a la potencia 0
después la razón elevado a la potencia 1
después la razón elevado a la potencia 2
etcétera etcétera etcétera y como es una
serie entonces nos tomamos la suma de
todos estos y es una serie
entonces no acabamos ahora lo que quiero
que veas y esto ya lo he visto en varios
vídeos es como encontramos una fórmula
explícita para saber cuánto vale una
serie como ésta yo lo que voy es como
encontramos una fórmula para encontrar
este tipo de series ahora aquí tenemos
un camino es uno entre k factorial
entonces por ahorita vamos a quitar lo
íbamos a tomar no solamente la serie que
nos queda que por cierto le voy a llamar
s voy a decir que ese es uno entre cada
0 + 1 entre k elevado en la primera
potencia más uno entre cada elevado al
cuadrado más y así hasta el infinito y
ahora qué pasa si yo multiplico uno
entre cada por ese pues me quedaría aquí
tendría uno entre cada cero por uno
entre camps quedaría uno entre acá a la
nueva potencia y después éste uno entre
acá a la primera potencia x uno entra
acá me quedaría uno entre cada elevado
al cuadrado y así no puedo seguir y
seguir y seguir y si ahora me tomo la
diferencia de estos dos entonces al
restar yo esté menos éste me va a quedar
uno menos uno entre camps esto que
multiplica a su vez a ese lo que estoy
haciendo es factor izando a ésta
y esto va a ser igual y date cuenta que
estos van a tener signo negativo por lo
tanto este con este se cancela este
cuando se cancela todos se cancelan
solamente me queda uno entre cada
elevado a la 0 pero uno entre ca elevado
a cero es uno por lo tanto ya la hice
porque el equipo de despejar a ese ese
va a ser igual a 1 entre 1 - 1 entre k
muy bien y ahora que ya tengo un valor
para ese entonces ya puedo sustituir a
esta s que era mi serie que tengo aquí
multiplicando la por caminos uno entre k
factorial caminos uno entre k factorial
por s pero ese vale 1 entre 1 - k y esto
de una vez lo puedo simplificar se
multiplicó a todo porque se multiplicó
todo porque entonces en la parte de
arriba me va a quedar acá y en la parte
de abajo me va a quedar acá menos cada
entrega lo cual es que al menos uno
perfecto entonces esto lo voy a escribir
aquí acá entre acá menos uno queda ni
más ni menos que ese y date cuenta que
quiero empezar a explicar cosas este con
esta se va entonces esto me queda cam /
caf actor y'all y como puedo escribir
acá factorial bueno no voy a poner aquí
esto lo mismo que acá
k factorial pero k factorial es lo mismo
que acá porque al menos uno por cada
menos 2 x etcétera etcétera entonces
déjame ponerlo cada que multiplica acá
menos 1 que a su vez multiplica menos 2
que a su vez multiplica todos los demás
hasta llegar a 1 hasta llegar a 1 porque
está acá y está acá se cancelan entonces
esto lo puede simplificar como uno entre
cada menos uno porque al menos dos
porque a menos 3 etcétera etcétera hasta
1 locales cada menos 1 factorial acá
menos 1 factorial entonces toda esta
expresión la puedo simplificar como uno
entre caminos 1 factorial y bueno si por
ejemplo quisiéramos sacar el primer
término es decir ese subíndice 1 que me
quedaría pues este subíndice 1 es
sustituir cada por uno y aquí me
quedaría uno menos uno lo cual es 0 0
factorial y bueno para no meternos en
estos problemas mejor lo voy a ver desde
acá 1 1 0 0 entre lo que sea es cero y
cero por lo que sea pues es cero aunque
aquí se simplificó y las cosas se
cambiaron aquí te da cero desde un
principio
1 - 1 0 y ya todo lo demás
no me importa porque cero entre lo que
sea es cero y cero por lo que sea de
cero por lo tanto ese subíndice uno es
cero
y qué pasa con ese subíndice dos es
decir cuando acá vale dos si sustituimos
cuando acá vale dos a ver en esta
expresión que obtendría 1 entre 2 - un
nuevo factor ya les decir 1 entre una
factoría lo cual es uno y bueno así me
puede seguir con este subíndice 3 este
subíndice 4 pero tengo 100 términos
entonces creo que no es la mejor opción
pero al menos ya sacamos 2 los primeros
valores para ese subíndice acá y
entonces si yo sustituyera aquí el valor
de este subíndice acá cuando acá vale 1
entonces no quedaría 0 por lo que sea lo
cual sería 0 y ahora si sustituyó cuando
acá vale 2 entonces no quedaría este
subíndice 2 lo cual es 1 y 1 por lo que
sea pues bueno dicho esto ahorita justo
es lo que voy a hacer entonces mejor
antes de meterme en ningún problema
déjame ponértelo aquí es que yo quiero
separar poco a poco los términos aquí me
quedaría uno y después acá me quedaría
puestos al cuadrado lo cual es 4 - 3 por
2 lo cuales 6 a esto
a sumar 14 menos 61 es menos 1 y menos 1
por unos buenos 1 pero con el valor
absoluto me quedaría 1 positivo es decir
que ya toda esta expresión la
posibilitar un poquito más en lugar de
estar tomándome desde acá igual a 1
hasta 100 mejor lo voy a tomar desde acá
igual a 3 hasta 100 y ya al menos el
resultado cuando acá vale 1 y cuando
acaba de 2 cuando acá vale 1 mi
resultado 0 cuando acaba de 2000 resulta
21 y después no voy a tomar la suma de
todos estos términos es decir desde acá
da igual a 3 hasta 100 de esta expresión
que tengo aquí del valor absoluto de
todo lo que está dentro de este
paréntesis pero ahora lo que quiero es
reducir lo más que se pueda lo que está
dentro de este paréntesis porque date
cuenta que este subíndice que como ya
vimos es uno entre caminos 1 factorial y
esto no nos sirve bastante para hacer
esta suma por lo tanto vamos a ver si
podemos simplificar un poco utilizando
que en la parte de abajo es decir en mi
denominador me queda acá menos 1
factorial y bueno ahora fijémonos en
nuestra parte de arriba si te das cuenta
esta expresión cada 4
- tres camas uno no está nada fácil de
factorizar esa era mi primera impresión
sin embargo tengo una segunda impresión
mi segunda impresión dice que tal vez
esto lo podamos reducir un poco
busquemos algo de la forma que al menos
uno o que al menos algo y de ahí vamos a
poder factorizar al menos un poquito más
esta expresión y es que casi siempre que
tengo estas expresiones yo por intuición
y por mucha práctica me doy cuenta que
este tipo de expresiones matemáticas nos
dan un comportamiento oscilatorio oa su
dado caso nos dan términos que se
eliminan muchas veces cuando tenemos
algo así pasan cosas como la que te voy
a poner aquí abajo hay veces que esta
expresión nos da términos como los
siguientes 12 menos 2 más 3 menos 3 y
así se sigue y sigue y se sigue y si te
das cuenta todos los términos de medios
se van cancelando el uno con el otro y
solamente me quedo con el primer término
y con el término final pero bueno vamos
a ver si puedo expresar de una manera
distinta acá cuadrada menos tres acá más
uno y fíjate que acá cuadrada
menos tres camas uno esto lo puedo
escribir como está cuadrada menos 2
1 - que dejemos ponerlo aquí está
cuadrada menos 2,1 menos camps y bueno
menos 2 k menos acá es lo mismo que
menos 3 camps pero lo estoy poniendo así
porque date cuenta que esta parte de
aquí acá cuadrada menos dos más uno es
un enorme cuadrado perfecto es k menos
uno al cuadrado entonces esto ya se ve
un poquito más bonito si yo lo pongo
como caminos no al cuadrado menos acá
así que déjame ponerlo aquí esta es la
parte de arriba de mi expresión de esta
suma es decir esto es mi numerador acá
-1 cuadrado menos acá y ahorita voy a
intentar simplificarlo un poco más
entonces ya lo pongo aquí déjame bajar
la pantalla y bueno basta recordar que
no hay que olvidar que al principio
tenemos un extiende al cuadrado entre
siempre actoral pero bueno eso lo
hacemos al final ahorita no hay que
preocuparnos mucho por eso nos quedan
uno más la suma desde acá igual a 3
hasta 100 del valor absoluto de esta
expresión que tengo aquí pero esta
expresión que tengo aquí la voy a
separar la voy a separar como caminos 1
al cuadrado entre caminos 1 factorial
menos acá entre carmen osuna factorial
es decir que me voy a tomar
la división de cada una de estas partes
tendría camino al cuadrado entre caminos
1 esto factorial y después por otra
parte voy a tener menos camps entre k
menos 1 factorial pero ahora quiero que
te des cuenta de lo siguiente cada menos
1 al cuadrado y aquí tengo acá menos 1
factorial que a menos 1 cuadrado es
caminos 1 porque al menos no esperes
vélez veces pero porque quiero realmente
ver otra cosita más bien quiero ver
caminos una factorial caminos una
factoriales caminos uno por caminos 2
porque a menos 3
así hasta 1 y ahora si tengo que a menos
1 al cuadrado ya que abajo tengo que a
menos 1 por caminos 2 por el 7 de este
tramo estos dos se pueden ir se puede ir
el cuadrado con uno de estos y solamente
me va a quedar acá menos uno entre cada
menos dos porque a menos tres porque
menos cuatro etcétera etcétera lo cual
es k menos dos factorial entonces en la
parte de abajo me quedaría caminos más
factorial y en la parte de arriba ya lo
simplifica un poquito es caminos uno a
secas y bueno a esto hay que quitarle
menos acá entre caminos 1 factorial y
ahora lo que quiero que veas y que tal
vez no está tan fácil de ver es que esto
que está aquí adentro
siempre es positivo y para esto mejor
vamos a verlo con ejemplos concretos qué
te parece si vamos variando la cab para
ver qué es lo que nos queda es decir voy
a tener uno más y ahora voy a sustituir
acá por tres acá por cuatro y bueno
hacerlo a mano no es la mejor opción
pero tal vez encontremos ya el patrón
que yo quiero cuando acabas de tres aquí
me quedaría 3 -1 locales 2 entre 3 - 2
lo cuales 11 factorial ya esto lo voy a
quitar 3 entre 2 factoriales 3 entre 2
factorial acá menos 13 menos uno los
cuales 22 factoriales ya esto le
sumaríamos qué pasa cuando acaba l 4
vamos a ver si encontramos un patrón
cuando acá vale 4 me quedaría 3 entre 2
factorial ya es donde tengo que quitar
cuatro menos tres factoriales date
cuenta que se empieza a cumplir un
patrón a ver qué pasa cuando acá vale 5
cuando acá vale 5 entonces no quedaría
pues 5 - 1 lo cual es 4 entre 3
factoriales ya esto le voy a quitar 5
menos
4 factorial 54 factorial y bueno así me
puedo seguir y seguir y seguir y me
tomaría la suma de todos estos hasta
llegar al término ciento vamos a ver si
podemos escribir el término ciento si yo
llegara a que acá vale siete entonces
que obtendrían cuando acá vale 100 me
quedaría pues 99 entre 98 factorial 99
entre 98 factorial ya esto le quitaría
100 entre 99 factorial y bueno ahora lo
que quiero que te des cuenta a espera
espera no hay que olvidar el 1 recuerda
que que aquí en un principio tenemos
este 1 entonces no quedaría uno más todo
esto ahora fíjate bien en esta expresión
si te das cuenta éste lo tenemos
negativo aquí positivo y negativo aquí
positivo y entonces los podríamos
eliminar pero justo en ese momento más
decir oye sal pero qué pasa con el valor
absoluto no podemos quitar el valor
absoluto de la nada pero lo que quiero
que te des cuenta es que este término el
negativo siempre es menor que este
término positivo aquí tendría por
ejemplo 2
tres medios y lo cual lo cual me da un
número positivo es justo lo más
importante de todo este problema darte
cuenta que esta expresión de aquí
siempre va a ser menor que esta
expresión de acá es decir lo negativo es
más chico que lo positivo y por lo tanto
siempre me van a dar valores positivos
aquí tendría 4 entre 3 factorial lo
cuales 4 sextos es decir dos tercios y
por otra parte tengo tres medios en el
otro tengo lo mismo y si esto es
positivo si esto es positivo y esto es
positivo y todo es positivo
entonces yo podría quitar el valor
absoluto porque el valor absoluto de
algo positivo pues siempre es positivo
entonces esto se podría quitar esto se
puede quitar esto se podría quitar y qué
creés ya aquí se ve claramente el patrón
al de que es lo que voy a cancelar
quitando el valor absoluto ahora si
tengo puros valores iguales alternados
uno negativo uno positivo uno negativo
uno positivo date cuenta que este y éste
se eliminan porque aquí lo tengo
positivo y aquí lo tengo negativo se van
este y éste se eliminan este y éste se
eliminan entonces como te decía todos se
van a empezar a eliminar hasta
este esto también se va a eliminar y
solamente me va a quedar 2 entre 1
factorial menos 100 entre 99 factoriales
1 + 2 entre 1 factorial lo cuales 2 ya
esto le voy a quitar 100 entre 99
factorial 100 entre 99 factorial y bueno
no había que olvidar por aquí un 100 al
cuadrado entre 100 factorial este que
está aquí el principio pero sin al
cuadrado entre 100 factorial es lo mismo
que 100% y abajo me quedaría 100 por 99
por 98 por así así hasta llegar al 1 y
bueno aquí un 100 con un 100 se puede ir
y me quedaría 100 entre 99 factoriales
entonces vamos a sumar a esta expresión
que tengo aquí abajo esta expresión de
aquí que siento entre 99 factorial
entonces vamos a sumar 100 entre 99
factorial y que buena suerte para
nosotros porque entonces este y éste se
van y solamente me queda 1 + 2 lo cual
es text la respuesta de este problema
tan raro que teníamos aquí es 3 y date
cuenta que lo más importante de este
problema fue encontrar una expresión
equivalente para
el numerador y además darnos cuenta que
lo que estaba dentro del valor absoluto
era positivo nuestra respuesta es 3